mesdames et messieurs merci de
d'être là ce matin pour
se compte rendu de 8 mois de travail qui
ont permis
d'aboutir à ses propositions concrètes
que qui vous seront présentés pour bien
recycler
à même groupe de travail de 21 membres
composés
de tous les groupes politiques avaient
travaillé avec 50 propositions pour les
libertés locales
aujourd'hui
ce que nous vous présentons c'est aussi
en quelque sorte la nécessité de la
réponse aux besoins de liberté
de simplification et de pouvoir d'agir
pour reprendre la formule du congrès des
maires de la semaine de l'année passée
pardonnez-moi
elle s'inscrit aussi dans comme une
réponse et une proposition j'y
reviendrai en conclusion au mot du
président de la République souvenez-vous
au moment il rencontre au mois de
septembre
le président de l'Association des maires
de France
le président de l'Association des
départements de France et la présidente
de l'Association des régions de France
il leur dit mais je souhaite faire une
grande loi de décentralisation
c'était pas la première annonce je le
reconnais mais la troisième et cette
fois-ci disons ça doit être la bonne et
donc nous avons préparé tous les
éléments pour qu'il y ait un vrai texte
non pas écrit en tant que texte ça
viendra plus tard mais qui soit un
ensemble de propositions et qui propose
une voie pour atteindre ces trois
objectifs de pouvoir d'agir de liberté
de libre administration des
collectivités et de simplification je
crois en effet que la décentralisation
de ce décrète pas dans les discours elle
doit se traduire par des actes je
voudrais rappeler la genèse du groupe de
travail qui va commencer le 5 octobre
dernier
il a
désigné
sous ma présidence ça rapporteur général
qui est François Noël buffet
trois rapporteurs notamment la
présidente de la délégation
collectivités territoriale Françoise
Gatel Matthieu d'Arnaud qui précise
aussi notre délégation à la prospective
et qui forme un binôme assez redoutable
depuis un certain nombre de textes
engagement et proximité 3DS et qui
naturellement ont travaillé ensemble
derrière et aux côtés du rapporteur
général et le rapporteur général du
budget Jean-François Husson parce que
naturellement nous avons inscrit comme
premier axe c'était vraiment aussi le
souhait qui était le nôtre que le retour
à une autonomie financière et fiscale
était le préalable à
tout toute intention de décentralisation
et puis avec Stéphane artado que
j'excuse
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon des pas
toujours à côté du sida
il y a le rapport de la délégation
aux outre-mer qui est un élément
extrêmement important parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé un moment de l'appel de
Fort-de-France on a évoqué l'évolution
dans les outre-mer c'est un point
important donc je n'irai pas beaucoup
plus loin si ce n'est que
je crois que
c'est un appel aussi à la responsabilité
la nécessité
d'agir et quand je vois la méthode qui a
été utilisée
vous aurez ce rapport dans lequel vous
avez aussi alors il a été adopté
avec aucune voie contraire un certain
nombre de groupes se sont abstenus nous
avons même eu une abstention
bienveillante mais la majorité je vois
l'abstention bavéante d'ailleurs ici
présent
en Didier Marie qui a beaucoup travaillé
avec nous et qui représente le groupe
socialiste
ici mais c'est naturellement adopté à
l'unanimité des votants et vous avez les
contributions
d'un certain nombre de groupes qui sont
annexés dans le rapport je sais
immédiatement la parole aux rapporteur
général merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur bonjour Je un propos général
évidemment que que je fais au nom de
l'ensemble des rapporteurs qui sont ici
présents et bien sûr de notre collègue
Artano à l'occasion du travail que nous
avons effectué nous sommes d'abord et
forcée et ça a été le principe de
dresser un état des lieux objectifs de
la situation actuelle de nos
collectivités nous avons évidemment pris
à appuyer sur des auditions qui ont été
conduites notamment des représentants
des élus le constat est en réalité sans
appel les collectivités territoriales et
leurs élus ont aujourd'hui réellement
perdu le pouvoir perdu oui j'ai dit bien
ça perdu leur pouvoir d'agir nous avons
identifié d'ailleurs trois obstacles
précisément à cette difficulté le
premier d'entre eux c'est évidemment
c'est presque une redite le carcan
normatif qui est tout au quotidien
l'action des élus singulièrement les
mers bien sûr ce phénomène n'est pas
nouveau je viens de vous le dire mais
l'accumulation des normes est de plus en
plus nombreuse de plus en plus complexe
et rend très difficile leur action au
quotidien on peut même parfois
s'interroger sur des normes la victoire
en tous les cas cela mérite d'être redit
mais surtout d'être résolu il en rajoute
finalement un sentiment qui est
largement partagé de dessaisissement de
leurs compétences et de nombreuses élus
locaux nous ont dit clairement qu'il
n'avait plus les moyens d'agir et qu'ils
étaient en réalité et bien sans capacité
de pouvoir faire à titre d'exemple mais
il y a beaucoup de sujets les
rapporteurs ils reviendront sur
l'urbanisme qui est notamment le cœur
pour ne pas dire oui si le cœur de
l'action des mers deuxième sujet ce
n'est pas la moindre difficulté le
système de financement des collectivités
territoriales dans son ensemble est à
bout de souffle Jean-François Husson le
précisera bien évidemment chacun sait
ici que la question du financement
Selena de la guerre la libraministration
et le pouvoir des collectivités locales
dépend très largement de ce point la
baisse continue de la fiscalité locale
sur les dernières années
incontestablement porté atteinte au lien
démocratique indispensable opéré entre
l'impôt les citoyens et les
collectivités territoriales je contribue
sur mon territoire parce que je vis sur
mon territoire et je participe
directement à la vie de ce territoire
aujourd'hui la suppression d'un certain
nombre d'impôts locaux finalement mais
une distance entre l'habitant et son
propre territoire de plus ce système ne
garantit pas aux collectivités
territoriales un dynamisme de ressources
est un sujet de fond et une visibilité
suffisante pour
exercer ses compétences ces règles sont
devenues et j'envoie ce sont nous le
redira à la fois incohérentes illisible
et en réalité elle peine les élus sont
en difficulté pour se retrouver dans ce
maquillage troisième élément du constat
c'est que les collectivités
territoriales non plus en l'état
non pas à l'égard de l'État ou de la
part de l'État un partenaire qu'ils ont
connu autrefois il y a un
contestablement là aussi un changement
profond désengagé de la Puy au
territoire notamment en matière
d'ingénierie on le constate
régulièrement l'état est perçu
finalement aujourd'hui comme un simple
censeur de l'action quotidienne des
collectivités territoriales
l'usure l'attrition de ces moyens au
niveau territorial c'est sans surprise
traduite par son incapacité à troquer
son rôle de contrôle pour celui
autrement plus constructif de conseils
face à ce risque nous avons travaillé
naturellement tous ensemble pour
déterminer cet axe qui sont d'ailleurs
affichées sur les tableaux que vous avez
devant vous auquel s'organise autour de
quelle organise nos propositions le
premier de ces axes c'est le
renforcement du pouvoir d'agir des élus
nous savons tous les élus souhaitent
avant tout conduire les projets seuls en
réalité l'hyperproximité et l'adaptation
territoriale sont les parents de
l'efficacité des politiques publiques il
faut leur redonner ce pouvoir d'action
le rapport formule à cet égard plusieurs
propositions dans les domaines diverses
mais là encore je ne veux pas priver de
parole mes collègues qui ont travaillé
sur le sujet le logement les aiderait
l'urbanisme le médico-social
y compris les sujets très concrets du
RNB qui s'inscrivent d'ailleurs dans la
saison actuelle et la façon dont on a
parfois de la résoudre les problèmes de
manière uniforme sur le territoire
singulièrement vous savez c'est la
technique du jardin à la française alors
qu'à l'inverse il faut s'adapter au
territoire et laisser les yeux locaux
agir le deuxième acte c'est évidemment
la coopération locale les relations
entre les communes et les
intercommunalités sont parfois source de
friction mais la maturité du fait du
fait intercommunal sont aujourd'hui
acquises et qu'il n'est plus besoin de
le renforcer par des dispositions
législatives nouvelles il est plutôt
grand temps de refaire de
l'intercommunalité un lieu de projet et
de dialogue entre les élus locaux le
fonctionnement intercommunal doit
conséquent cette assouplie y compris en
modifiant la répartition des compétences
entre communes et intercommunalité n'ont
pas forcément par voie législatives mais
par accord local de même il paraît
nécessaire de soutenir les formes
choisies de coopération locale à
l'exemple des communes nouvelles sur la
base naturellement du volontariat des
communes concernées cela va sans dire
nous savons tous compris que l'imposer
quelque chose ne fonctionne pas et que
tout cela doit venir du terrain et de la
volonté des élus locaux de faire bouger
les choses troisième axe que nous avons
retenu c'est la création d'un statut de
l'élu qui soit attractif et protecteur
l'actualité a montré et montre toujours
les difficultés des élus locaux je n'ose
même pas dire simplement des difficultés
les agressions dont ils sont aujourd'hui
les victimes qu'elles soient de nature
délictuelles au criminelles et nos
orbières ont marqué qu'elle pouvait être
évidemment criminelles sont
inacceptables nous avons fait des
propositions en fait elle se traduit ces
propositions et j'associe évidemment
française Gatel Matthieu Arnaud Maryse
Carrère et nos prisons de groupe
respectifs à la PPL que nous avons
déposée dans le titre de renforcer la
sécurité des élus locaux et la
protection des mers nous l'avons déposé
fin mai et nous espérons monsieur le
Président sous votre contrôle qu'elle
pourra être inscrite à l'ordre du jour
du Sénat à la rentrée parlementaire 14
articles qui viennent ici favoriser la
protection des élus locaux et des maires
en particulier
certes je suis le premier signataire de
ce texte mais nous avons travaillé avec
les collègues ils sont évidemment
associés sans difficulté à ce travail
heureusement d'ailleurs c'est notre
force le quatrième axe c'est la
libération de l'initiative locale notre
cadre constitutionnel peut être égard
constitué un obstacle nous pensons le
président la rappeler aux situations de
nos outre-mer dans un cadre
constitutionnel qu'il faudra rénover
pour dépasser les questions entre
l'assimilation la spécialisation
législative s'adapter à la
différenciation des territoires le
rapport de notre collègue Arthaud dans
ce point là tout à fait instructif qui
fait les pistes qu'il a tracé et que
nous partageons seront travaillés le
cinquième axe axe pardon c'est très un
état déconcentré nous proposons en la
matière de faire du préfet du
département
l'interlocuteur unique des mers et des
élus locaux il faut rendre le rendre
garant de l'unicité de la parole de
l'État sur les projets locaux c'est
absolument essentiel de retrouver ce
lien de confiance entre les préfets et
les mers mais au-delà du lien de
confiance la capacité de pouvoir décider
des projets locaux et ce en toute
transparence mais aussi en toute liberté
ce que l'on a qualifié d'ailleurs de
circuit court et je crois
qu'effectivement
c'est à la fois en circuit court et puis
aussi
j'allais dire de avec des sucres rapides
parce que nous en avons besoin je
reprends une expression déjà utilisée
par d'autres dans d'autres circonstances
sur d'autres sujets mais le circuit
court
jumelé au sucre rapide devrait nous
permettre de retrouver de l'efficacité
il est absolument nous proposons
également de mettre fin la logique
d'appel à projet dans l'accès à
l'ingénierie public et de préférer une
logique d'accompagnement sur mesure afin
de laisser aucune collectivité sur le
bord de la route et nous proposons de
sécuriser les décisions des élus locaux
en développement les risques y compris
préfectoraux pour préférer le conseil au
contrôle le sixième axe est consacré au
finances locales nous y formulons 4
propositions je ne rentre pas dans le
détail de celle-ci Jean-François Husson
lefras il est le spécialiste du sujet
bien évidemment mais il est clair qu'il
faut réformer de fond en comble notre
système de financement la proposition
numéro 10 que nous faisons est là pour
cela il faut que les élus locaux
retrouvent la maîtrise de leurs
ressources et puis savoir une protection
constitutionnelle cela est une de nos
propositions enfin le septième axe c'est
le rôle du Parlement singulièrement du
Sénat et une en sont rôle de contrôle
nous avons besoin de déployer une
palette d'outils de contrôle qui doivent
être adaptés et dédiées à l'application
au territoire des lois votées en
particulier de systématiser le contrôle
qualitatif à tous les échelons de
l'application d'une norme par ailleurs
nous devons nous législateur
collectivement nous restreints de nos
astreintes exactement à la sobriété
normative va se programme un grand homme
d'État aurait dit mais nous devons quand
même nous inscrire dans cette logique je
vous remercie de l'attention j'étais
sans trop long mais Françoise Gatel
Matthieu d'Arnaud et Jean-François
Husson sont là pour préciser ces lignes
que je viens de vous décrire merci à
vous je vais donner la parole il y a un
peu un symbole nous sommes dans la une
salle peut vous sembler dans l'élévation
spirituelle mais qui porte le nom de
redémonorer et nous venons de faire
mémoire de son centenaire mais il a été
à de ceux qui dès 82 et d'ailleurs
parfois en ramant contre j'allais dire
les sensibilités
a dit qu'au Sénat les textes qui étaient
présentés dont nous avons fêté le 40e
anniversaire était des textes essentiels
retrouvez quelque part l'esprit de 1982
c'est aussi un objectif or depuis 15 ans
disons les choses comme elles sont nous
avons vécues une large recentralisation
une verticalité qui s'est accélérée et
malgré tout et on l'a vu encore
récemment qu'est-ce qui est au premier
rang c'est toujours les maires les
conseils municipaux donc les choses
soient claires nous voulons pas
simplement faire un rapport de plus mais
je vous dirai la suite que nous
donnerons c'est un rapport pour marquer
une vraie rupture par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé 15 ans voilà pour qu'il me
semblait il nous semblait important que
ça soit dans la salle qui porte le nom
de René Monory qu'on se retrouve
aujourd'hui Françoise Gatel
merci merci monsieur le Président
cela a été dit par le président
l'architeur et le président buffet
l'ambition que nous servons elle est
simple et en même temps s'il exigence
que c'est un peu perturbé nous rappelle
c'est l'obligation d'efficacité de
l'action publique et jusqu'au dernier
dernier kilomètre pouvoir agir le
président l'a appelé c'est très
compliqué parfois dans notre pays et
pour les élus parce que je pense qu'on a
un état qui s'est encombré et qui joue
souvent un rôle de contremaître c'est à
dire il contrôle il veut
tout embrasser et qui trop embrasse mal
étreint et que le circuit court dont
parlait le président buffet c'est cette
conscience de dire que les choses
doivent être réglées au niveau c'est
parfois le niveau communal c'est parfois
le niveau intercommunal la région
cantaletta aucune loi territoriale qui
était faite depuis 1982 n'a traité de ce
qui revenait à l'état serre les
compétences régaliennes que l'État doit
exercer au nom de l'unité de la
République donc nous ce que nous
proposons c'est cette exigence
d'efficacité qui passe par un état
centré sur ce qu'il doit faire et qu'il
pourrait faire bien et qui avait enfin
c'est cette révolution culturelle que le
président appelle de ses vœux une
relation de confiance naturelle et
continue avec les collectivités qui
s'affairent qui osent faire et qui ont
surtout l'obligation d'inventer des
solutions qui marchent et je pense que
aujourd'hui il est plus que temps avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard chacun peut le
dire un peu calmement et qu'en même
temps nous devrions tirer les leçons de
manière définitive des crises que nous
avons au vécu ou ce que j'appelle
l'armée des ombres serre les mers les
conseillers municipaux dont parfois on
se désintéresse
au niveau national cette armée des
hommes à chaque fois on l'appelle en
renfort quand on agit le plan sec des
crises c'est la crise des gilets jaunes
c'est la crise sanitaire et c'est encore
nous l'avons vu aujourd'hui ces acteurs
locaux qui s'engagent pour résoudre des
difficultés et compensées donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'heure le président l'a
dit c'est plus au discours parce qu'on
doit tous partager ce même diagnostic et
je donnerai quelques exemples de ce que
doit être
ce droit qui donne la capacité
d'inventer les solutions alors le
président buffet a parlé de la liberté
alors on parle beaucoup de Airbnb
aujourd'hui on a une législation
nationale qui dit que dans toutes les
communes de France il vous a pas plus de
120 nuités d'Airbnb alors que quand on
regarde de près pardonnez-moi un peu une
petite Brest touch à Saint-Malo les 120
c'est beaucoup trop et en même temps on
a dans le centre de la France des
territoires ruraux qui ont un patrimoine
environnemental ou bâti extraordinaire
qui leur levier de développement et qui
sont en train de signer des partenariats
avec Airbnb pour permettre d'accueillir
des touristes et ainsi renforcer le
commerce et peut-être que pour eux 120
nuits ou un peu plus seraient une
excellente réponse donc l'idée c'est
bien de faire dans dans la dentelle de
façon à être très efficace alors on l'a
dit l'État qui est parfois un
contremaître je le dis d'une manière un
peu brutale il doit se détendre et doit
surtout être en accompagnement des
collectivités parce qu'aujourd'hui un
main il peut plus supporter quand il a
un projet d'aménagement
frapper à la porte de la BF à la porte
de la Dréal à la porte d'un autre
service et à chaque fois on lui donne
une réponse qui se contredit qui
l'empêche de faire et que l'État doit
faire un changement culturel il doit
être là pour accompagner et permettre
que les élus puissent entreprendre et
réussir il faut que le préfet on a un
rapport de nos collègues canaillé qu'il
a démontré le préfet c'est le chef
d'orchestre des services de l'État un
moment ils coordonne et on doit pouvoir
parler d'une voix unique et puis un
autre point très important c'est celui
de l'engagement des élus alors nous ne
cessons depuis 2019 le décès tragique du
maire de signe nous avons déjà au Sénat
acter des choses valider des choses la
loi est venue améliorer la protection
fonctionnelle des élus les élus ne sont
pas au-dessus des lois mais quand ils
exercent au nom de l'État à certains
membres de fonctions ils doivent être
protégés dans l'exercice de ces
fonctions alors il faut aller un peu
plus loin dans la mise en oeuvre de tout
ça mais je crois et François Noël buffet
la rappeler une proposition de loi a été
déposée pour reconnaître le rôle parce
qu'on est ici dans un lieu un peu
particulier sacré au nom du sacré de la
République des élus et des mères et puis
ça ne suffit pas vous savez qu'en 2020
sans si commune sont restés sans
candidat au moment des élections
municipales c'était 80 en 2014 et
aujourd'hui on constate
des démissions des découragements non
seulement des mers mais des élus
municipaux il y a une vraie inquiétude à
avoir pour les prochaines échéances que
serait notre pays qui est fort de
commune très vivante si nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui
citoyens qui ont envie de s'engager et
que donc dans les prescriptions que nous
faisons nous voulons donner aux maires
le pouvoir d'agir mais aussi l'envie de
l'envie de servir et l'envie de
s'engager et tout citoyen doit être à
même de pouvoir s'engager on doit avoir
une France d'élus qui correspond à la
diversité de notre société des étudiants
qui peuvent avoir envie de s'engager des
élus qui aujourd'hui travaillent des
femmes qui ont besoin de concilier leur
vie professionnelle et leur vie
familiale et donc nous souhaitons
vraiment qu'il y a un accompagnement
pour faciliter tout cela que l'État
prenne en charge et facile l'engagement
mais qu'on permette aussi aux élus de
sécuriser leur sortie et de retourner à
l'emploi donc il y a une vraie ambition
et des propositions extrêmement
concrètes pour faciliter l'engagement
Mathieu Dardeau
oui merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs moi je vais me borner
sur un mot qui à mon avis résume à la
fois l'état d'esprit du Sénat et celui
des élus locaux de ce pays c'est je
crois l'urgence à agir et ce rapport il
porte à la fois une volonté et un esprit
une philosophie de liberté mais il
rappelle à l'envie qu'il y a urgence à
agir et pardon de le dire avec un peu de
solennité mais quand je vois hier encore
l'audition que nous avons eu de la
ministre s'agissant de la question du
statut de l'élu alors que le Sénat a
commis des 2018 un rapport auquel 17000
élus locaux émerent ont répondu et qui
présentent de façon exhaustive tous les
pans qui constituent finalement les
différents domaines d'action du statut
de l'élu et bien ce rapport il est là
pour
souligner la cohérence sénatoriale dont
nous avons toujours su faire preuve
depuis notamment les grandes lois de
réforme territoriales en disant à peu
près à chaque fois la même chose et puis
dire aussi au gouvernement qu'il peut
déjà se saisir de ce rapport sans lancer
une énième concertation qui débouchera
sur un nouveau diagnostic et des
nouvelles mesures qui se heurteront en
elle-même à une nouvelle concertation
pour lui dire que déjà sur la question
de l'état des concentrés nous avons des
pistes de solutions qui sont applicables
dès aujourd'hui faisant de l'État et du
préfet de département cet ensemble y est
comme Françoise Gatel l'a rappelé parce
que nous ne voulons plus que l'État
territorial soit un hydre de Lerne à 5
têtes où on aurait d'un côté
l'adréal de l'autre côté la drague les
services de l'éducation nationale les
élus veulent plus de liberté plus
d'agilité et surtout de l'efficience
dans la réponse donc ce rapport il est
là pour dire nouveau proposons des
solutions qui sont prêtes à l'emploi
dont l'étape lui-même se saisir d'ores
et déjà et nous avons toute expertisé et
on peut dès la rentrée imaginer je pense
que le président du Sénat l'ajustement
rappelé que le Sénat jouera tout son
rôle notamment en matière de contrôle
parce qu'il est en aussi de rappeler
l'État à ses engagements et de dire que
maintenant nous pouvons d'ores et déjà
faire en sorte que ce rapport jette les
bases d'une action immédiate en urgence
qui répondent réellement aux besoins
quotidiens des élus du territoire
français qui ont encore été mis à
contribution durant ces derniers jours
pour faire face comme ils l'ont fait
durant la crise des gilets jaunes comme
ils l'ont fait durant la crise sanitaire
et je crois que et j'en finirai par là
ce rapport c'est aussi un hommage que
nous leur rendons en étant finalement à
l'écoute de leurs besoins et de leurs
aspirations je vous remercie
le rapporteur général du budget oui tout
ça dans un contexte
ou la dette de la France c'est à passer
les 3000 milliards avec une
interpellation à l'endroit des finances
des collectivités locales d'abord pour
redire ce qui a très bien dit le
rapporteur général de ce groupe de
travail sur la décentralisation on est
aujourd'hui avec un système de finance
locale qui est à bout de souffle et
pourtant et pourtant les finances
locales financent de manière concrète
en portant la majorité de
l'investissement public
la transition écologique les sujets de
déplacement la modernisation des
équipements tout ce qui fait la cohésion
sociale et territoriale de notre pays
en limitant l'endettement de notre pays
je crois que ça doit toujours être
appelé c'est efficacité de
l'investissement public proximité et
finalement
territorialisation répondant aux besoins
mais on a on a aujourd'hui une
difficulté c'est France annuel buffet
l'a dit la suppression d'un certain
nombre d'impôts ont fait disparaître en
tous les cas grandement à moindry le
lien entre l'acteur le citoyen l'acteur
économique et son territoire est bien
nous pensons qu'il faut aujourd'hui
rendre
constitutionnel les éléments de la
fiscalité pour chacun des niveaux de
collectivité c'est une garantie
indispensable qui doit être mise en
place et puis
être attentif en ayant également un
regard sur ce qui s'est passé dans ce
qui s'est passé c'est les compétences
qui sont exercées par les collectivités
un certain nombre on fait l'objet de
transfert la compensation se fait à
l'euro près au moment du transfert et
bien nous nous proposons qu'il y ait des
évaluations régulières de cette
compensation si il y a une dérive
notamment en termes de dépenses il faut
pouvoir corriger les effets et si à
l'inverse il y a des effets une
amplification des bénéfices il faut
savoir en tirer également les conclusion
ça fonctionne et ça doit fonctionner
dans les deux sens et puis enfin et
peut-être surtout j'ai parlé de
l'investissement des collectivités
locales et notamment de boulon communal
et bien aujourd'hui
c'est un
méli-mélo de dispositifs de dotation
diverses et multiples et là encore prend
Sonel buffet l'a très bien dit avec
lorsqu'on ne sait pas par quelle porte
d'entrée on sort régulièrement des
appels à projets qui sont des coûts
finalement éphémères et bien nous
proposons de d'avoir une réflexion
beaucoup plus aboutie et pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs pour faciliter
l'investissement public de mettre un peu
de l'ordre à la fois en simplifiant pour
rendre les choses plus fluides et en
invitant pourquoi pas d'ailleurs à
travers une expérimentation l'État
et les collectivités locales à avoir une
peut-être une dotation unique de l'État
à l'endroit des collectivités et
pourquoi pas en l'expérimentant c'est à
dire que ça doit ça devrait être à la
fois la base d'un contrat et la base est
intégrant la plurianualité tout cela
parce que ça voudrait dire que l'État
est en capacité d'avoir le bon niveau
dialogue avec les territoires et de se
mettre d'accord sur des priorités dont
on convient à l'exemple de ce qu'a dit
France asgatel il y a quelques instants
que parfois les priorités ne seront pas
les mêmes selon les régions selon les
communes selon les départements et bien
c'est aussi cela faire vivre un nouvel
esprit de décentralisation
merci alors très concrètement bonjour
vous puissiez questionner les
rapporteurs qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de
ça
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de ça d'abord
je retiens que les élus ont besoin de
liberté et que les citoyens ils ont
besoin de proximité donc
ce travail qui est rendu aujourd'hui
on entretien avec le Président de la
République lundi je l'ai évoqué je lui
ai dit que nous lui ferions porter comme
je ne le feront porter à la première
ministre comme à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il est
indispensable que le gouvernement s'en
empare mais de toute façon va s'en
emparer puisqu'il va donner lieu à la
rédaction de proposition de loi qui au
cours de la cession qui s'ouvrira le 1er
octobre seront examinés par le Sénat je
le dis on pourra pas faire une annonce
comme nous l'avons entendu au mois de
septembre dernier du président de la
République sans que ça se traduise de
manière concrète je le dis extrêmement
clairement je vous dis clairement que je
serai engagé sur ce point aux côtés des
rapporteurs j'allais dire de tous les
groupes politiques j'insiste qui ont
participé à ce rapport
j'ajoute un point
qui est un exemple
la marginalisation des mers dans les
politiques d'attribution de logements et
de peuplement
c'est un sujet majeur je l'ai dit au
président de la République et je vais
vous dire là-dessus on lâchera pas
on lâchera pas
et que les choses soient claires le
président de la République s'est engagé
devant les mers on les recevant
mardi nous avions évoqué parce que ça
c'est du concret
c'est du concret parce que c'est ça qui
crée ou pas la cohésion dans une
collectivité et c'est un signe de
confiance parce que on voit bien qu'en
15 ans on s'est éloigné du rôle et de la
place du maire notamment dans ses
politiques de logements voilà je voulais
très très clair c'est pas fait pour être
un rapport de plus les rapports c'est
bien mais maintenant passons aux actes
c'est vraiment le message que je voulais
vous dire vraiment remercions tous les
rapporteurs et j'allais dire les 21
membres du groupe de travail parce que y
compris les contributions ça démontre
que c'est quelque chose d'important vous
avez la parole
allez-y question délire
bonjour Guillaume Jacquot de Public
Sénat comment vous qualifiez aujourd'hui
vos propositions en comparaison de
celles que vous avez faites à l'été 2020
les 50 propositions sur les libertés
locales est-ce que c'est une nouvelle
tentative après la loi 3DS qui a qui est
loin d'avoir répondu à toutes les
réponses au niveau local ou est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui va beaucoup plus
loin que vos travaux il y a 3 ans
comment vous voyez les choses donnez la
parole au couple de 3DS et d'engagement
et proximité
je pense que cela a été dit y compris
par Mathieu Darnaud il y a une
persévérance dans nos convictions qui
n'est pas de l'entêtement ou de
l'obstination mais c'est parce que nous
pensons nous l'avions déjà dit qu'il est
urgent d'agir et que les clés de
l'action elles sont au final assez assez
simple et que dans 3ds nous avons on va
dire fin d'essai qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui transformer parce que je
trouve qu'à l'époque il y avait beaucoup
de timidité de la part du gouvernement
et que nous étions
comment dire d'une grande un peu timoré
dans l'accueil de nos propositions et
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que nous savons
que le principe c'est un État fort sur
ces compétences et des élus qui
inventent des choses donc nous sommes
aujourd'hui le président lundi dans la
détermination d'aller au bout et de
valoriser le travail de fond qui est
fait parce que je crois qu'il y a au
Sénat une constance une exigence et une
écoute des territoires qui est je crois
un service qui peut être rendu au
gouvernement s'il tend l'oreille nous
pouvons ensemble contribuer parce que
non pas parce que nous souffrent nous
souffririons d'un complexe de
supériorité en disant nous savons c'est
pas du tout ça mais je pense que tout le
monde entend ce que disent les mains et
l'exigence surtout de la population et
que la cohésion sociale au calme il se
fait à ce prix là donc ce sont des coups
de bélier successifs qu'on donne dans la
porte on va dire
d'un État qui est
très très dur très autoritaire et très
fermé il faut ouvrir
et permettre d'aller au bout et je
trouve que là on a des propositions
extrêmement concrètes comme celles que
le président a dit sur le logement je
pense que si on laissait les mers
organiser les choses ça se passerait
mieux et qu'aujourd'hui dans nos
communes nous avons des concitoyens qui
ne comprennent pas pourquoi bien que sur
une liste d'attente depuis fort
longtemps eux ou leurs enfants ils ne
peuvent pas être accueillis dans un
logement social parce qu'il y a un quota
qui est imposé par le préfet Matthieu
oui très simplement et très directement
j'ai le sentiment que depuis 2017 on
peut dresser
un bilan qui s'apparente à l'autopsie
d'un gâchis on lance ici même le
président de la République en 2017 la
Conférence nationale les territoires et
on a sur en termes de traduction
législative selon la vue même et les
propos des ministres eux-mêmes un texte
qui corrige les irritants d'une loi
précédente et le deuxième qui finalement
la loi 3DS est une boîte à outils
j'indique juste au passage et je vous
invite à faire l'exercice si vous avez
quelques instants à regarder le nombre
de décrets d'applications qui ne sont
toujours pas pris 18 mois après le vote
de la loi 3D et vous verrez quand même
par l'effet la démonstration que la
politique des territoires ça reste
définitivement l'angle mort de la
politique du gouvernement et bien nous
face à ça on veut que ce texte qui
s'inscrit encore une fois dans une
philosophie tout à fait constante du
Sénat reprenait toutes nos propositions
depuis le vote de la loi notre et vous
verrez qu'à chaque fois on essaie de
donner de l'ampleur et j'en finirai par
dire qu'à chaque texte 3DS comme
engagement et proximité nous avons fait
œuvres utile et je pense que les
principaux apports de ces textes sont
issus du Sénat sur l'intercommunalité
sur la répartition des compétences sur
justement cette
cette esprit de liberté que nous n'avons
cessé de marteler qui se retrouvent dans
quelques dispositions de ces textes mais
à l'évidence pour répondre directement à
votre question ce rapport c'est une
invitation à aller beaucoup plus loin
beaucoup plus vite
excusez-moi quelles alliés et qu'elle
relève pensez-vous avoir au sein du
gouvernement pour avancer sur ce
chantier de la décentralisation et je
veux dire après des décennies de de
résistance de l'État central des années
de recentralisation
pensez-vous que que ça puisse inspirer
la DGCL le ministère de l'Intérieur
Bercy comment est-ce que vous qualifiez
un petit peu les alliés et les relais
que vous pourriez avoir pour donner une
suite concrète à ce rapport
là
est-ce que vous pensez que ce qui s'est
passé la semaine dernière
pourrait servir de d'accélérateur dans
la dans les décisions de l'exécutif
je peux me permettre
si ça sert pas d'accélérateur si on ne
tire pas le moment venu après la
réflexion à certains nombre
d'enseignants d'enseignement c'est à
désespéré
je peux vous le dire pour l'avoir vécu
mon département dans le département du
Val-d'Oise
les élus ont été encore une fois en
première ligne
il y a un espèce de devoir absolu
pardonnez-moi de pas faire simplement
une nouvelle grand-messe et puis que
derrière il se passe rien je vais vous
le dire j'en ferai personnellement
une tâche
prioritaire pour le président du Sénat
les discours on a eu les propositions on
a maintenant faut des actes
je prends l'exemple du logement mais il
y en a d'autres est-ce qu'on quand
elle parle qu'il faut que le préfet
territorial il y a eu un débat dans
notre groupe de travail
retrouve l'autorité sur les services de
l'État
sa tenue sur quoi en ce moment la
semaine dernière sur le dialogue entre
les maires et des préfets
ça devrait être une leçon
les cris successives que nous vivons
démontrent ça alors si on en tire aucun
enseignement et mon entiera des
conséquences politiques je le dis
clairement et fermement
je pense que je suis clair sur le sujet
voilà répondre à votre question sur
l'inspiration nous ne cessons de de dire
que nous espérons incarner au moins une
source d'inspiration pour le pour le
gouvernement mais plus sérieusement je
crois que la force des travaux que nous
avons commis et des rapports que nous
avons rendus et des textes que nous
avons essayé d'enrichir depuis
maintenant 2017 on tousse un point
commun c'est leur caractère
opérationnel tout ce que nous proposons
peut être appliqué nous avons eu pendant
la loi 3DS un débat très long avec la
ministre de mon Chalin qui avait pris
l'engagement que dans le comité
interministériel ou ruralité qui
suivrait l'examen du texte il y aurait
des annonces fortes pour redonner
l'agilité et plus de simplicité au
niveau de l'organisation territoriale de
l'État pardon de le dire on est trois
ans après il y a pas le commencement
d'une mesure qui a été mise en place pas
une il y a des choses qui sont d'une
simplicité pardon mais public fondé
refonder et faire en sorte qu'on ait
qu'un fond d'État sur les territoires
DETR des cils fond vert c'est quand même
pas compliqué et en plus personne ne
viendra contrarier je veux dire le
travail de l'État puisque c'est l'étal
lui-même qui notifie qui instruit ses
dossiers deuxièmement faire en sorte et
là on est tous d'accord l'ensemble des
groupes du Sénat que le préfet coordonne
l'action dans les territoires ça paraît
aujourd'hui une absolue évidence on le
dit maintenant depuis six ans quatre ans
l'État pour en tirer des conséquences si
ce n'est peut-être une volonté
effectivement de tourner le dos
définitivement et philosophiquement la
décentralisation pour engager l'État sur
une voie sans retour de reconcentration
et de recentralisation et là
effectivement on a une différence
politique notoire
peut-être ce que je souhaiterais dire
c'est que dans les propositions qui sont
faites ce sont des propositions en
réalité de bon sens
personne ne perd de pouvoir tout le
monde retrouve de la liberté
les mères retrouvent de liberté le
préfet devenant l'interlocuteur unique
retrouve de la liberté dans ses
relations avec les mères on est dans la
simplification de du travail état
collectivité locale donc on ne renverse
pas la table on a simplement la volonté
que les choses fonctionnent et soit
effective sur le terrain pas au service
des undotes au service de la population
tout simplement et des territoires on ne
demande pas la lune
on n'est pas là avec une proposition qui
vise à repenser toute l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales on s'en est
bien tenu à l'écart volontairement
d'ailleurs parce qu'on a bien le souci
d'une réponse concrète
et effectivement et vraiment c'est tout
mon garçon pouvoir mais tout le monde
trouve de la liberté et c'est la
conjonction des deux qui fait que ça
peut marcher
monsieur quand on n'est pas spontanément
inspiré ça nous arrive à tous on apprend
parce que je pense que dans notre pays
personne ne peut être en désaccord avec
l'objectif que nous poursuivons qui est
l'efficacité de l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier habitant et s'il
fallait faire un plaidoyer pour cet
objectif les différentes crises que nous
avons traversé que nous traverserons
montrent que cela s'impose je dirais
comme Monsieur Jourdain faisait de la
prose et maintenant il faut vraiment
mais vraiment y aller c'est cette
exigence là et nous ce que nous
demandons ce n'est pas de défendre les
élus et les collectivités comme un Graal
devant lequel on se vénérait mais ce que
l'on cherche que l'on veut et je
n'imagine pas un gouvernement qui soit
pas en phase avec cet objectif c'est de
l'efficacité parce que nos concitoyens
ne nous pardonneront pas et
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement il est là
au bord du vide si je puis dire c'est
maintenant ou ça ne sera pas et ce sera
grave
bonjour Perrine Vasse pour BFM TV
monsieur Larcher vous avez parlé que les
mères se sont entretenues avec le
président cette semaine ou le savon et
qui lui ont parlé notamment des
problématiques des politiques de la
politique de la ville j'aimerais
vous dire les propos que vient tenir le
président de la République à Pau il est
en ce moment même à Pau autour d'une
cinquantaine d'élus et sans le vouloir
il vous a répondu j'aimerais que vous
puissiez rebondir sur ce qu'il vient de
dire les maires d'îles présidents
disaient le problème c'est la politique
de la ville vous n'avez pas mis assez
d'argent j'aimerais bien que ce soit le
cas est-ce une question de moyens ce
serait trop simple qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez merci
d'avoir une question d'humain
et que celui qui est proche de la vie de
son territoire
pardonnez-moi c'est le maire son conseil
municipal et que c'est ça l'essentiel si
le président de la République n'a pas
entendu ce que je lui ai dit lundi je
lui rappellerai c'est Homère d'ailleurs
lundi mardi il avait tenu un langage un
peu différent au maire je lui rappelle
que faire confiance aux maires en lien
avec les présidents de département
notamment sur les questions sociales en
lien avec les présidents de région sur
l'aménagement mais pardonnez-moi les
politiques de peuplement sont des
politiques essentielles difficile à
comprendre à l'extérieur mais vous êtes
que les six bien les questions des
collectivités territoriales vous savez
que il faut résoudre des aspects
concrets dans une vie dans une ville que
l'intégration c'est aussi le résultat de
ces politiques là et que l'intégration
c'est l'objectif de faire communauté
nationale alors si on n'a pas compris ça
si on continue avec des schémas des
schémas régionaux de logement des
schémas départementaux de logement on
décide à la place des mers ce qu'on
construit à bien ils se construira plus
rien je vais vous le dire il faut se
poser les vrais questions et je réponds
pardonnez-moi directement poliment
que je maintiens ma proposition que je
lui ai faite que j'avais cru qu'il
l'avait entendu mardi devant les maires
peut pas avoir langage le mardi et un
langage de jeudi qu'il soit différent
voilà
vous avez dit que vous alliez traduire
une nombre de ses propositions via des
propos des propositions de loi dès la
rentrée avant ça il y aura un
rendez-vous important qui sera le budget
2024 dans lequel le Sénat aura un jour
un rôle primordial à jouer qu'est-ce que
vous allez mettre comme priorité pour
traduire les propositions là dans le
budget 2024 et deuxième question qui
s'adresse plus spécialement à la même
Gatel et Monsieur Darnaud on parle
beaucoup de différenciation le président
de la République en parle beaucoup je
suis pas certain que vous soyez vous en
parlez également puisque vous souhaitez
inscrire ce principe dans la dans la
Constitution je suis pas totalement sûr
que vous soyez aligné avec le président
de la République là-dessus et j'aimerais
bien avoir votre avis alors sur l'aspect
budgétaire Jean-François Husson
d'abord je voulais dire on est dans un
contexte d'inflation de dépenses
publiques préoccupant un niveau de dette
inquiétant donc on arrive à un moment
d'épreuve de vérité
et je pense que au-delà des mots il faut
regarder pour réduire progressivement
notre dette
définir de nouvelles priorités pour la
dépense publique et je crois qu'il vous
a pas échappé que les collectivités
locales j'ai l'occasion de le dire dans
mon cours propos
participent grandement à
l'investissement public
en nourrissant peu d'endettement puisque
sur l'endettement public vous savez
c'est de l'ordre de 8%, c'est donc des
investissements qui répondent mieux
aux besoins des populations et des
acteurs économiques que l'investissement
qui est porté par l'État qui souvent est
financé par du déficit et de la dette
et quand vous ajoutez la dette
budgétaire à la dette climatique
je crois qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
regarder nos concitoyens et l'avenir
avec sérénité donc il faut siffler la
canne à récréation je ne suis pas sûr de
ce que j'entends jusqu'à maintenant
puisque l'an passé on avait eu droit à
des expressions de Bruno Le Maire sur un
budget à l'euro près excusez-moi mais
l'euro il a le budget le repris la
grandement dérivée donc aujourd'hui on
nous fait des
Assises des finances publiques ben
écoutez moi j'attends de voir mais il
vous a pas échappé non plus que dans la
période intercalaire on a toujours pas
de projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques dans ce projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
ce serait bien d'arriver à une division
convergente et les visions convergentes
de casque vise aujourd'hui le ministre
si je j'ai bien tout lu c'est un effort
qui est assez proche de celui qu'on
proposait
juste avant Noël pour nous expliquer
qu'on était très brutaux que ça allait
être pratiquement du sang et des larmes
donc la difficulté c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas faire changer les Français et
surtout les élus qui eux il y a 36 000
responsables enfin 35000 si on prend les
communes comme ça ben je dirais d'un
revers de manche ou de propos
et donc nous essaierons de faire en
sorte à la fois de remettre de l'ordre
dans nos finances publiques il faudra
redéfir des priorités mais l'État va
devoir et le gouvernement va devoir
écouter et entendre les demandes qui
viennent du territoire des territoires
que ce soit par les associations d'élus
mais surtout là où la décision se
travaille et se débat le Parlement est
bien évidemment le Sénat je crois qu'il
faut changer le paradigme vous a dit que
le financement des collectivités locales
était aujourd'hui
illisible les élus s'y perdent il faut
donc moi je pense que c'est mieux c'est
pas plus de dépenses c'est mieux
dépenser c'est une dépense plus efficace
qui donne de la satisfaction à nos
concitoyens et pour ça c'est plus facile
si vous préparez avec l'État et vos
partenaires les projets que l'on choisit
de financer ensemble dans certains
endroits ça va être l'adaptation du
système éducatif et donc de l'école du
collège il y aura des embrastes ras des
lycées mais il y a aussi besoin de
moderniser des équipements regarder
l'état aujourd'hui de grands équipements
sportifs et culturels construits dans
les années 60
aujourd'hui on est en grande difficulté
et comment voulez-vous que les Français
n'est pas dans les territoires qui sont
touchés ce sentiment de déclassement
d'être éloigné de la décision politique
c'est pour ça qu'il faut rapprocher la
décision et qu'il faut écouter la
prendre en compte les demandes des
territoires quand on est écouté on est
reconnu et on recrée de la confiance
oui je crois que la différence c'est
finalement peut-être ce qui nous
distingue le plus de la méthode qui a
été employée nous nous considérons que
la différenciation c'est finalement
observer qu'il y a des vérités
territoriales qui nécessitent une
souplesse des adaptations mais la
différenciation c'est pas adapté la loi
aux besoins des territoires nous nous
refusons d'imaginer que demain on va
détricoter le
l'architecture institutionnel française
selon le bon vouloir de tel ou tel élu
de tel ou tel territoire non pour nous
la différenciation elle est très simple
à appliquer la différenciation elle peut
finalement s'opérer avec la
territorialisation de l'action publique
tout simplement et c'est ce que nous
proposons dans ce rapport c'est un état
incarné par le préfet de département et
c'est un tout petit peu plus de liberté
laissé aux élus des territoires pour
prendre en compte les spécificités
locales
par exemple pour être très concret dans
une intercommunalité qui est plus ou
moins rural plus ou moins urbaine
laisser peut-être une latitude à
l'exécutif intercommunal et aux communes
de faire remonter au redescendre
certains de pentes compétences c'est
tout simplement ça la différence mais
c'est surtout pas faire des adaptations
législatives tous les quatre matins pour
pardon donner le sentiment qu'on est
dans une forme de clientélisme
territorial nous on est très clair on
peut encore une fois à droite constant
opérer une forme de différenciation qui
conjugue avec l'exigence déficience je
le dis et encore une fois c'est la
vérité de notre rapport c'est d'ores et
déjà l'État peut se saisir des mesures
que nous proposons pour aller dans
l'urgence répondre aux besoins des élus
des territoires de France je pense que
ça encore une fois c'est essentiel et la
différenciation ça ne doit pas être un
machin de plus qui n'est pas défini et
qui permet de répondre de façon très
insatisfaisante à des besoins exprimés
territorialement parce que sinon
malheureusement encore une fois on va
détricoter le fil de la confiance entre
les territoires et l'État
ce débat est profondément
intéressant le mot différenciation fait
parfois peur mais encore une fois moi je
reprends l'exemple de la prose de
Monsieur Jourdain mais il a
différenciation de la loi en est pleine
le gouvernement vient de proposer un
agenda pour la ruralité c'est sans doute
qu'il y a dans des territoires heureux
des particularités on parle de communes
du littoral de commune de montagne des
petites des grands des plans pour la
différenciation c'est juste prendre en
compte les diversités de situations pour
atteindre l'égalité de droit donc la
différenciation c'est pas la
déconstruction de l'unité de la
République bien au contraire pour
permettre l'exercice de l'égalité de
droit il faut donner des moyens
différents selon les particularités des
territoires et je pense que on est
d'accord sur la conscience des choses on
a juste peur d'utiliser ce mot qui sera
un gros mot et une infraction encore une
fois l'unité de la République c'est bien
le contraire
qui s'adresse plutôt à Monsieur buffet
non concernant votre proposition de loi
que vous voudriez voir à l'ordre du jour
inscrite à la rentrée
qu'est-ce que concrètement il y avait
dedans parce qu'elle a été rédigée fin a
été déposé fin mai est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un peu concrètement ce
qu'il y aurait dedans et l'urgence que
pointe le président du Sénat
pourrait-elle être répandue par cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie deux
axes principaux la volonté de renforcer
le quantum des peines à l'égard des
actes
délictueux délictueux au criminels des
mers donc on augmente on met au même
niveau si vous voulez l'atteinte
physique au maire que une atteinte aux
autorités telle que la police les
gendarmes ou les pompiers donc ça c'est
cette volonté très ferme de renforcer le
quantum des peines et puis c'est l'autre
aspect qui est de renforcer la
protection fonctionnelle des des maires
aussi à la fois quand ils sont victimes
d'agression pas seulement s'ils étaient
les auteurs éventuels vraiment quand ils
sont victimes d'agression et enfin de
renforcer le lien et de structurer
concrètement le lien mère procure la
République préférée certes dans le
territoire globalement les préfets les
maires se parlent pas de difficultés
c'est un peu plus difficile en ce qui
concerne la justice et les procureurs de
la République avec les maires je ne dis
pas que ça ne fonctionne pas il y a des
endroits où ça fonctionne très très bien
ça dépend souvent de la qualité du
procureur et de la volonté de celui-ci
d'avoir un contact avec le mail à
l'écoute des élus locaux ce que nous
voulons pour éviter par exemple ce qui
s'est passé à Saint-Brevin pour faire un
exemple très concret pour éviter ce type
de difficulté on veut organiser ce lien
et que de façon
établi j'allais dire juridiquement
législativement
cette relation soit inscrite dans la loi
et que finalement les programmes avec
quel qu'il soit n'est pas le choix que
d'être en relation régulière avec le
maire d'avoir un lien
physique téléphonique dans tous les cas
systématique dès lors qu'un maire et
victime de pression ou de d'agressions
le contact s'établissime immédiatement
et que la réponse judiciaire soit
également mise en place donc c'est
vraiment ces deux trois aspects qui sont
au cœur des 14 articles de la PPL
pardon mais rien n'empêche que elle
puisse être nourri
je comprends pas non non non on n'a pas
dans le dans le texte qui est proposé il
y a il y a pas de d'articles qui vise la
politique de la ville
concernant le logement dont vous
pointiez
dans le temps la Conférence des
présidents de la semaine prochaine
inscrira le principe pour la rentrée
de renforcer la sécurité des élus et la
protection des mers ça c'est la première
priorité en ce qui concerne les
propositions de loi nous allons d'abord
voir les réactions de l'exécutif à nos
propositions et entre-temps il
appartient de transformer ses
propositions en proposition de loi
c'est-à-dire en article il y a beaucoup
de recommandations comme le disait nos
rapporteurs qui n'ont pas besoin
certaines nécessitent un petit contrôle
pourquoi la DGCL mettant de temps à
prendre un certain nombre de décrets
pourquoi les préfets sont toujours pas
au fait dans beaucoup d'endroits y
compris des contrats de mixité sociale
quand même il y a des comptes à rendre
et un des rôles du Parlement c'est le
contrôle de l'application de la loi et
c'est ce que nous allons faire il y a me
semble-t-il une exigence vraiment
contrôlée parce que c'est très bien
d'avoir des débats mais il comprend on
prend pas les décrets derrière quand on
les met pas en oeuvre et quand on
adresses pas au préfet les bonnes
circulaires qui vont bien pardonnez-moi
c'est un dysfonctionnement grave et
c'est notre rôle de le contrôler donc il
y aura les rédactions vous savez que
l'automne n'est pas un temps très
favorable pour trouver des créneaux de
discussions de proposition de loi mais
elles seront préparées l'automne et
elles seront présentées le moment venu
ça leur appartient après c'est plus le
travail du Président du Sénat travail le
président du Sénat c'est de dire qu'il y
a dans ce pays une nécessité
d'en finir avec la rue centralisation il
y a la nécessité de retrouver de la
proximité pour les citoyens et de la
liberté pour les élus et une relation de
confiance entre l'État territorial à une
décentralisation retrouvée nous avons
besoin d'un état territorial fort et il
n'y a pas d'opposition entre les deux
c'est ça l'objectif avec pragmatisme
bien on a fait le tour
merci beaucoup merci à vous vous avez vu
qu'on était plutôt décidé
que
mais pour votre information que le
groupe de travail institutions
souvenez que le Président de la
République avait dit qu'il proposerait
un groupe transpartisan qui est devenu
transgroupe de réfléchir sur les
institutions et
le nôtre a commencé son travail en
novembre dernier il le reprendra à
l'automne il a le même rapporteur qui
est le président de la commission des
lois et nous ferons des propositions à
la fin de l'année sur le groupe de
travail institutionnel car des aspects
constitutionnels mais qui a aussi des
aspects tout simplement de
fonctionnement de la démocratie et
nous avons suspendu nos travaux en
attendant l'Assemblée nationale un tout
petit peu je sais que c'est très
difficile et je fais nul reproche pour
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
de pouvoir réunir un groupe de travail
comme le nôtre tout groupe politique
confondu c'est beaucoup plus complexe et
je me mets à sa place mais nous
reprendrons nous avons déjà examiné
toutes l'élection présidentielle toute
la question des cumules des mandats
toute la question du fonctionnement de
la démocratie et on va la poursuivre
participative par rapport à la
démocratie représentative nous avançons
nous avons examiné ce que devait être
l'évolution éventuelle de la Cour de
Justice de la République du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature des
relations
entre les magistrats et les élus tout ça
avancé il nous en reste à faire mais
attendez-vous un jour est invité à la
fin de l'année pour qu'on vous parle il
y a toute la partie constitut il n'y a
pas que la partie ca ce qui nous
préoccupe c'est le fonctionnement de la
démocratie ce qui nous préoccupe c'est
j'allais dire le niveau de participation
à ces temps de vie démocratiques nous
aborderons aussi nous l'avons déjà fait
la partie référendaire
donc et toutes ces parties-là donc c'est
pour la fin de l'année nous aurons
rempli les deux réponses et les deux
invitations à l'avance du président de
la République une grande loi de
décentralisation c'était en septembre et
c'était en juin de l'année dernière
le dialogue autour de l'évolution
institutionnelle et démocratique donc
nous rendrons notre copie à la fin de
l'année je vous souhaite un très très
bel été voilà merci beaucoup